SCP-682 Vs Y-909. Can the compound derived
from SCP-3000, the legendary Ananatashesha,
be the thing that finally ends
the wretched life of SCP-682?
Y-909 is the key ingredient
in Foundation amnestics,
and the researchers discovered a curious
thing when it was added to 682’s tank:
It caused an increase in the damage that
hydrochloric acid did to the creature’s body.
This suggested that 682’s regenerative
abilities are somehow tied to its memories
of previous damage taken. Some researchers
proposed taking SCP-682 directly to SCP-3000,
to see if the giant eel could
kill 682 once and for all.
However, this proposal was soundly rejected,
due to too many unpredictable factors:
From the risk of transporting 682, to its
unpredictable adaptive response to SCP-3000,
such as it possibly growing to SCP-3000’s
insane size or stealing its amnestic abilities.